what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and
today we have something very very
interesting to talk about there has been
a supposed leaked description for the
second spider-man knowing home trailer
that would be the official trailer since
the first trailer that we got although
it was freaking awesome was only a
teaser which makes us look forward to
the second trailer even more in the
teaser trailer they actually revealed
the multiverse and they revealed some of
the villains of this sinister six well
they really revealed all of them except
for one but i definitely was not
expecting to see a pumpkin bomb or doc
ock show up at all in the teaser but
since they did it makes you wonder what
they're going to show in the official
trailer and i know the whole world is
wanting toby maguire spider-man and
andrew garfield spider-man to show up in
this official trailer so we know that
they're in the movie before it comes out
although we have had a lot of different
reports some plot leaks that were proven
to be real thanks to the teaser trailer
coming out say that toby maguire and
andrew garfield are in the movie even
though we have things like that of
course it's not confirmed until we
actually see them and according to this
trailer description that i'm about to go
over they are this won't be the first
report that we've gotten some other
people like big screen leaks have also
reported that in the final shot of the
official trailer we're going to see the
other two spider-man with tom holland
and i think that's all we really really
want from the trailer in all honesty
just show us the other two but let's go
ahead and start going over this
description of what this second trailer
is supposedly going to be now i gotta
add that this is not confirmed to be
what the actual trailer is going to be
it does line up with some things that
we've heard but since it's an anonymous
source on instagram posting this there's
no way to tell if it's real or fake
however it's still very interesting to
think about and hopefully this actually
is what we see because it's very
intriguing and if you want to stay up to
date on spiderman now way home consider
subscribing to the channel and hitting
the notification bell so like i said
i'll link this to some other things that
we've heard but first let's just go over
it now here are the photos that were
shared it makes it look like these
photos were kind of like swiped from a
computer screen or something like if
they are real somebody took a picture of
them and they weren't supposed to but
who knows so i'll read exactly what it
says and then we'll break it down it
starts off by saying spider-man no way
home exclusive trailer 2 leaked
description authority and ownership sony
pictures they state that like that's
actually going to help them if sony
actually catches them it says the
trailer begins with peter mj and ned
talking about the court that's the next
day ned tells him that he is a minor and
they cannot put him in without an
extension peter tells them not to let
them be in danger which i think actually
means peter tells them that they are not
in danger and i should have added that
this was actually i think translated
from russian so the translation won't
match up exactly peter says it is no
longer the world i know and then it cuts
to the sony and marvel logo there are
repeated scenes from the first trailer
but in this trailer the spell of strange
is better explained and we see different
scenarios of different villains from
other sagas we see the scene where doc
ock appears on the bridge and talks to
peter parker and peter says to him who
are you and what do you want and doc ock
replies with i'm finishing what i
started it then says we hear willem
dafoe's green goblin speaking to tom
holland spider-man saying in my twisted
ways i asked for your help i admit it i
am aggressive but that is my nature and
then it says these words are
complimented by a scene where we see all
the villains and peter seeing all the
villains surprised we then see a
disembodied sandman in a cell we see the
lizard and then we see elektro making a
huge lightning storm we can see
lightning strike the city and we can see
all of the villains we hear the words of
dr strange speaking to peter parker
saying the multiverse is just one
percent of what we know if you mess with
reality enough it will end up affecting
yours we then see peter kissing mj and
we see ned crying then it says we see
the trial of peter parker then a shot of
a fight with lizard in the subway it
says that the sixth member of the
sinister six is rhino from the amazing
spider-man 2. and this is something that
has been kind of rumored but not
confirmed in any way we see doctor
strange taking peter through the
multiverse we then see peter in his new
black and gold suit fighting against
electro in the sky it then cuts to the
spider-man no way home logo it then
shows us one last scene of the trailer
which shows the three spider-men
fighting together against the sinister
six it says the two other spider-men do
not remove their masks but they have the
same costumes as their respective
characters meaning toby maguire is
wearing his outfit from the sam raimi
spider-man universe and andrew garfield
is wearing his from the amazing
spider-man universe now if this is what
happens i'm really really okay with this
in fact i hope this is actually what we
see i don't actually want to see too
much of the movie with this trailer what
i really want for this trailer to do is
simply establish that these villains are
from the other universes there are still
people out there saying that doc ock and
the green goblin and all these other
villains could be from other universes
than the ones we've already seen and
that they could just be variants and not
actually from the tobey maguire universe
in andrew garfield universe so i'd like
established clarity on where exactly
they're from which it seems like they're
kind of going to give us a little bit of
that doc ock says that he's going to
finish what he started green goblin says
something about asking peter for help so
hopefully we learn a little bit more
about the villains and where they come
from now it also says that doctor
strange's spell is explained and i think
this is something that we could use some
clarity on as well who remembers him who
doesn't does aunt may know it's him does
ned know it's him mj what exactly is he
in for and then of course it ends by
saying that we do see the three
spider-men now i know people have a lot
of mixed feelings about this if the
other two spider-men are indeed in the
movie should they actually show them in
a trailer or should they wait and just
let people find out while watching the
movie and arguments can be made for both
now ultimately i kind of hope this plot
leak isn't true because i don't think we
should see all three spider-men together
fighting how i would love for them to do
this is for peter parker tom holland's
peter parker in one scene to turn around
and be like who are you guys and then we
see just like the arms of both
spider-man like from behind or like a
silhouette don't give us like this big
full reveal we want to see it all really
on screen what we really want is that
confirmation in the trailers that's what
we're all just holding out for just show
us and confirm now one thing that this
trailer leak does say is that rhino was
going to be the sixth member of the
sinister six and it also does mention
the lizard which we kind of saw in the
first trailer it's still very hard to
make out if that is indeed the lizard or
venom when i watch that scene in 4k i
don't see a tail and it does have kind
of the build of venom now i'm guessing
that it probably is the lizard and we
just so happen to not be able to see his
tail in this shot i obviously know all
of the things that happened in venom let
there be carnage including the post
credit scene but i think that when they
finally do meet up venom and spider-man
it's going to be in like the post-credit
of no way home or in a completely
different film i actually think that
venom 3 is going to take place entirely
in the mcu and that's when we're going
to see venom go up against spider-man i
actually don't think that it's going to
be a spider-man film with venom in it
but we'll have to wait and see on that
however rhino being the sixth member of
the sinister six would make sense it
seems like there are three villains from
each respected universe from the raimi
universe we have sandman the green
goblin and doc ock and then from the
amazing spider-man universe we would
have electro the lizard and rhino and
the only thing that's kind of weird
about this is that we already have
established villains inside of the mcu
and it doesn't look like we're going to
be seeing any of them in this film or if
we do maybe it's just going to be
briefly there's been no mention or leaks
or anything about vulture about scorpion
chameleon the tinker nothing but if it
is a multiversal film which we know it
is from the first teaser trailer and we
know that doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness is going to kind
of be dealing with the repercussions of
spider-man knowing home and a bunch of
other projects as well then it does make
sense that the villains are going to be
from other universes so i think if this
is the trailer that we get a lot of
people will be excited especially if
they do show the three spider-man at the
end but i stand by what i said hoping
that we don't get shown too much of the
other two spider-man in the trailer but
let me know what you think in the
comments down below would you rather see
them in the trailer or not wait till the
film let me know and don't forget to
like this video and for live updates you
can always follow me on instagram and
twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof
you